The joe rogan experience,
you're,
you'll,
you lose.
One of the things and when you do the
math is that you'll lose your ability to
see what's smart and what's not smart.
Like you just,
you lose that with every drug.
It's just not meant.
Don't blame it on meth.
Don't blame him.
I met,
met the list.
I don't think he moves it with weed.
No,
but you lose it with the heart.
You get deliveries.
You get your judgment is fucking foil.
That's what drugs do to your judgment
is fucking off and you catch yourself
sometimes you're like,
what the fuck did I just do?
Wow.
That's real scary part
about sometimes you're like,
what the fuck did I just,
and that's what a lot of
people are looking for,
Ryan.
A lot of people are looking
for this fucking big burst of,
of escape.
You know,
they're looking for something that just
blows the mat or whatever the fuck their
life is because they're
looking to just escape.
They don't like life.
They don't like it.
They want you to die.
Man.
I want to get hot and they
want to get high to escape,
escape reality.
You know man,
we get your back hurts,
your back hurts,
you hurt your back.
It fucking hurts bro.
You gotta go to a doctor.
You know the idea.
I did have a butterfly sweep.
I left my thumb up on the
fucking guy landed on my head.
How Chihuahua my son hurt and swell up.
I think when I needed the drugs he
was one of my whole body was in pain.
And it's not pain that you feel.
It's just as pain and its
well it's also you did it for so long
when your body became accustomed to using
it beginnings.
But in the beginning,
why is the main reason we get down?
Why is the main reason that guy like
you and lose you have pain in your life
growing up?
We all do.
What made you different than not doing it?
You know when you uh,
when you first get involved in that,
your body hurts man.
I kinda,
you know,
when I was 17 I go home at the end
of the night when I was in school,
I had to go to school at seven
30 not going high school.
Junior had to go to school and I would
come home and sit in the corner in the
dark wood.
Hey iPhones on with an
eight track black sabbath.
And I just do coke till
three in the morning.
He is Christ.
No drinking,
just to cope.
What possesses you
would do that Joe Rogan.
I don't know.
What's it,
cause that was a junkie.
No,
I was,
you know what?
I was in so much pain,
but pain covers this huge
thing when you're doing drugs.
Pain could be a,
you know,
fucking confusion.
Pain shows up as confusion.
Confusion shows up.
His pain is what I'm saying to you.
Confused.
So I was 16 it could be emotional pain.
It could be a launch,
doesn't have to be physical.
Whole body's in pain and you're doing it.
You know,
I talked to the head that I
talked to the kid I kidnapped,
you know,
I call him a lot now.
Well,
I'm guilty.
I'm really fucking guilty of that because
I saw something when I kidnapped them
that it's not Joe Diaz.
I saw him suffering.
I saw him at one moment on the floor
handcuffed and I would never want that to
me.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I always dreaded that happens to
a friend of mine for what I did and I
always felt bad.
I had him call on the podcast and I
apologize to him and I always call him up
and I called him the other day and
we were talking and they told me,
you know,
every time I talked to him,
he tells me more about his life,
Bro.
You know what happens
since I kidnapped him,
I bumped into him in [inaudible] 94.
I kidnapped them and 87,
I bumped into him in [inaudible]
94 and I bought coke from him.
He was all fucked up.
It's at,
uh,
at um,
pro street down in boulder.
And then he never remembered.
I think he blacked out.
That's how bad a shape he was in.
I asked him the last,
not this time though,
at the time before I asked him,
do you remember me buying blow from you?
He goes,
I remember seeing it.
I remember hating you
the next day and leave.
I didn't knock you the fuck out
because I caught him off guard.
He was at a bar all fucked up on
like you guys saw me some blogs,
like I look goes here.
The guy who kidnapped me,
the guy who kidnap me,
but I called them license blow after.
After you kidnapped him in before
you apologize for kidnapping,
she was later.
Yeah,
I saw him at a a bomb pro street.
Did you even say,
I'm sorry I kidnapped you.
Not that night.
I just gave him a hug and asked him if
he knew where I get some blow his shit
not that night gave me a hug and
I always go on the bottom of one.
I apologize.
That felt really bad and I talked to
him and Danny and he started telling me
he's 50 he was,
it was mother.
He had a heart attack.
You know,
I could tell when I talked to him on
his pictures on Facebook that he had a
stroke,
you know,
that was off from the blow bro.
Sometimes when he calls me
and I can tell he's drinking,
you know,
and sometimes I feel real guilty.
Did I do this?
But then,
you know,
I'm the type of guy,
I don't play that shit.
You know,
I don't play that shit at all.
He was fucked up when
I get in that though,
a couple of weeks before,
you know how we got hot,
this whole thing started was because
he got a Dui fucked up some cars,
went to bold the hospital
on North Hospital,
older general.
And while he was in there,
you know,
boulder,
he was hurt.
They left them in a room by
himself when he stole a ball,
liquid cocaines and jumped out the window.
Okay.
And they caught him and I laid
on the other side of the boat.
When you steal a bottle of liquor,
cocaine from the hospital
you already got proud of.
I'm like,
God kidnapping him,
you know?
And we laugh and we giggle.
Me Kidnapping Him.
It makes me feel blank.
Maybe I contribute to that,
but I didn't.
He had his own doom.
Why didn't I get fucked up?
You know?
I mean,
I got fucked up and in different ways,
I paid in different ways because the
guilt in me doing that to a man fucking
destroyed me.
You know?
I like to fuck around.
I could do something bad
if somebody harms me.
But even with Jujitsu,
I just can't put my
forum in somebody's face.
Man.
I hate when I have to lay on somebody.
Like I'll check on him and go,
you okay bro.
You know I love you right now.
Let me know.
I know.
He know.
It's funny.
So for me,
seeing him in that corner,
I always had that guilt
that I tied him up.